I just thought I would give you just a
quick snapshot of who I am and I won't
go that much into Avon it's um it is an
interesting company 140 something
countries you know well over ten billion
dollars today with six million Avon
representatives so I think we have more
Avon representatives than the army the
Air Force and the Navy combined in
Brazil and over a million won in China
so the numbers are huge but let me just
tell you one thing about myself which I
think will start this and that is that
um I I think I'm I'm in this job ten
years as of last Wednesday ten years as
a CEO which my father he sent me an
article he usually doesn't do this that
had on the cover of Businessweek that
the average tenure was at that time 3.2
years and he said to me with this big
question mark like are you coming home
and I would say to you first and
foremost that you know I have a love
affair with my work in my company not
love this job every single day which we
can talk about the CEOs job after 40
public quarters particularly in the last
couple years is not exactly what I would
say is fun but I have had a huge passion
for it and I guess I would just express
this by telling you that in 1997 I was
on a short list of I guess potential
CEOs for the company and there was a lot
of visibility on it for those of you who
are women in the audience because I
think at that time there was only one
woman maybe two Carly Fiorina and Marian
Sandler were the only two public company
CEOs at the time and so I was in line to
become the CEO of the company the
company hit a sort of tough spot and the
board decided even though they had kind
of given me the nod that I would get the
job that they were gonna go with one of
our directors a gentleman who had been a
CEO and was 52 years old so they told me
that I was not gonna get the job and
that I could be the number two and the
papers and the New York Times kind of
really we're all over that because there
was this whole overwhelming women passed
over there is a glass ceiling reaction
to it at which point I got actually two
other pretty big CEO job offers so I was
at this inflection point because there I
was the boss that I was gonna work for
was 52 so it wasn't like he was 62 or
they could tell me just do this for a
couple years and then you'll get the job
and they basically were saying he's here
you you are you're here to support him
and I was being offered the money the
title the corner office that came with
some pretty interesting benefits and a
mentor of mine said follow your compass
not your clock I just say that again she
said follow your compass not your clock
make this decision not from your head
but from your heart and that was the
biggest inflection point of my career I
made the decision that I love the
company I loved its mission its purpose
we were in a tough time I love the
people and I decided that I love that
more than I loved the idea of being a
CEO or anything else that came with that
that I would rather be with the company
and work I loved then just do it for the
sake of the title and quote the path
that you were supposed to be achieving
and in that decision I think that
changed my life and changed my life
career-wise I will tell you you know it
didn't work out for him so I got the job
in 21 months in the rest is history but
I just I'm starting I'm starting to tell
you because I I don't know who else
would be here on view for the top
because I would make that decision again
even if I was still number 2 today other
things take precedence when it's not
deep passion for the work so I just that
that's the first thing I wanted to tell
you is that
luckily life turned out for me and I get
to be here and do this but it wouldn't
have mattered if it didn't because I've
actually found a company that I that I
love
most important thing I wanted to share
with you before we even started starting
back then how did you manage to stay
true to your passion in your dreams well
I was interesting because I mean mom and
dad came from China came here to give us
education and hopefully you know Ivy
League education z' and then going into
not different than your parents doctor
lawyer or just something they thought
more intellectual than retail so when I
decided after Henry here it recruited me
to go and work in the retail business I
think their first reaction was that that
really wasn't what we had in mind but
then the family values set in which were
no matter what it is you do then then
you better go and be your best you
better go and you better work hard and I
remember oh gosh it was just by
Thanksgiving of that first year in that
training program and I was changing
hangers in a stockroom and all I was
doing was taking the vendor hangers it
was it was worth that I'm being very
nice about this
I was taking the vendor hangers and
putting the store hangers on this
thinking to myself I got and I remember
one day thing and to my mom I don't know
I mean it yeah so it could be really
interesting but I really feel like I'm
doing some menial work here and I don't
know maybe maybe I should quit and she
said to me in less than a heartbeat she
said to me quit we don't quit in this
family are you kidding quit you start at
the bottom and you work your way up your
Oh what is it that you are learning from
that you are not quitting I don't care
who else is in that training program
that's quitting quit on anything in this
family and that that perseverance even
though when they quickly got over it now
they think it was great they tell the
story they have all the scrapbooks about
it but that wasn't like that but that
thought really was resident in and I
think you know our family's culture so
it was just whatever you decide to do
stick with it
it's not going to be easy no no path to
success comes without stones in it so
you know you have to take some tough
days you're gonna you're not gonna like
it a lot of the time but that's just
part of it stick with it don't quit I
feel really proud that I haven't had to
change who I am
to be successful in this role dan Rather
was doing this series of interviews when
I first became the CEO of a couple of
women executives and he was actually
went and interviewed families parents
and so he went they went up and
interviewed my parents my mom cleaned
the house we're trying to serve him
Chinese food
and they you know they do this huge
thing for like hours and hours and you
know how those of you know media I mean
they shrunk it down to about a 20-second
soundbite after interviewing for hours
and hours and hours with all of this and
they take it down to one sound byte on
television where he's asking my father
so did you always know that your
daughter was going to be a successful
CEO and he says on public television as
a matter of fact quite the opposite you
know we raised her we raised our kids
it's pretty traditional Chinese Family
Values and my perception of
CEOs really hardcore cutthroat I really
can't imagine that she's gonna actually
be that successful so but the truth is
in that thought was the fear I think
that my family values system had that
the concept of being kind about caring
about people about being respectful
would go get washed out of the window in
a very you know very in his mind typical
behaviors required in the corner office
and have I had to change some things yes
I mean I I think I am much more
assertive I mean you know kind of
growing up in an Asian background sort
of avoid conflict around the dinner
table is the thought you don't argue
about things and I have had to become
more assertive and have understand the
role of constructive conflict I don't
think I'm aggressive got five point five
and a half million sales representatives
around the world how does that play into
how you motivate them how you get them
inspired and how you lead the
organization well it's interesting
because they are they are independent
representatives so I underline that word
I mean different than I guess other CEOs
there they're not my employees they
don't have to work for me every day so I
can't tell them what to do you know you
learn and the skill is interesting one
and I guess it applies anywhere whether
I guess it's politics or anything else I
mean influence is a very different thing
motivation inspiration and influence are
very different things than leadership
requirements and mandates and so you
know this skill of communicating is the
skill of influencing and inspiring and
mission and values and purpose have been
the way that we've effectively kept that
sales force going this year you and I
had a little conversation on the way
over but you know no different than any
other company 2009 you go into the buzz
saw of the global economic cry
just a year ago and everybody's like
okay we got a cut we've got to free
salaries we're not gonna hire we're
gonna do let you know whatever all the
the things that just come flying at you
as a CEO and we decided that we needed
to keep our people motivated but more
importantly you know go back to the
original purpose of the company in order
to find the answer for the way we were
going to get through this year and that
was that you know the company was he's
123 years old and the the founder
actually was a man who believed that
women should be economically empowered I
mean I actually loved the story he was a
encyclopedia salesman and all of the
direct sales sellers were men at the
time and somebody gave him about a vial
of perfume one Christmas and he realized
everybody who was home were the women
and they were basically saying to him we
don't want the books can we just buy the
perfume that you were supposed to give
as a gift with it
so he realized there was something there
but the most important thing he did
because it was 1886 was decide that the
seller wouldn't be men that he was going
to actually employ a woman which was
heretical at the time because women
weren't even allowed to vote never mind
make money outside of the home and it's
been extremely motivating and it's
almost no language necessary when you
have mission and purpose we did a very
bold thing you know a lot of people were
cutting back on advertising we decided
we're gonna advertise I remember the day
I said we're gonna advertise on the
Super Bowl this year and people were
like no the Super Bowl a it's expensive
B you know you know it's it's Budweiser
I mean those are the kind of products so
Andrea are we gonna advertise skincare
or lipstick and I said neither we're
gonna create an ad a testimonial ad of
people who've joined us since they got
laid off and they're gonna tell their
story everybody looked at us and we said
we went out and we created a very
compelling ad where the message was
authentic and genuine people really said
I can't get laid off I'm running my own
business
they're mine on ours it's my own
business my job and we ran it and the
phone was off the hook before half-time
as you can imagine for all the women
watching at the same time from the
pregame on and this began what has
become probably more people who've
joined then certainly in the United
States since the 70s it's been it's been
an amazing thing but it was this
proactive message that entrepreneurship
is in and it's important and it's part
of the economy solution I'm sure we
don't love to know kind of how you view
your leadership tiles being different
from Steve Jobs as you're Jeff the notes
in particular what you think Jeff before
I wear my jeans in my black but mark
told me I needed to wear soon very
different fascinating experiences so I
was you know I mean in this day and age
tough too tough to find the time because
I think boards take on I mean I think
this is this is a world and speaking for
a second just being a director the
responsibility of being a public company
director obviously is huge these days
and the commitment really is is it's
time-consuming but I was on GES board
since actually before I became the CEO
at Avon so I've been on that board 11
years now and was pretty much
exclusively on one board until I joined
Apple in 19 2008 so it was 10 years
before I joined the second board and I
did that I mean GE has been
extraordinary it's I didn't go to
business school my secret I wish I had
come here but since I didn't I didn't go
to business school and in a way it has
been my business school from from
everything of a process point of view on
one hand you would say aircraft engines
power systems medical systems a lipstick
and skin care completely different
businesses on the other hand the
processes globalization
quality programs how they do things
across the world as you know are hugely
beneficial to any business leader
I just want wondering if you'd speak a
little bit about how you reinvent
yourself as a CEO and how do you take a
step back reexamine there's something
different why I think you know the
company we like to say is 123 years
young and the only way to do that I mean
you can't reinvent a company without
reinventing yourself first so
reinvention of a brand or reinvention of
a company is only as good as the
reinvention of the leader and the
leaders and it is interesting and being
in the job ten years and yeah I think
it's a huge privilege on one hand I
actually don't know how people are kind
of coming into this job in this
environment and having to kind of put
all truths over here and start fresh
having had a decade of having to go
through cycles and reinvent myself and
learn from my own mistakes I think has
clearly been an enabler to getting
through this environment but I'll tell
you one story in so the first five years
I was a growth CEO I mean we were
booming into emerging markets we had
double-digit top-line growth 25 percent
earnings growth for five years running
and I mean I never did a layoff I had no
idea what the word turnaround man and we
hit the wall you know as all businesses
do and if you're in an any job long
enough I can promise you there is a
cycle whether it's silk there there's
business is cyclical whether it's Pharma
you you name it there's always cycles so
I've gone probably longer than not
without hitting the wall but we hit the
wall in 2005 and we at that time gave
earnings guidance and we missed guidance
twice in I don't know four months and I
don't know if some of you know Ram
Charan who was sort of a coach and
friend to CEOs he's been a friend of
mine for a long time but he came up into
my office on a Friday night and he said
to me you want some tough love and I
said sure and he said to me the board
loves you people in this company love
you but in about 120 days they're gonna
have to fire you
I just looked at him and he said you do
understand that right I mean
unfortunately when you're in this job
you got shareholders I mean if you can't
turn this around if you can't look at
this thing with new eyes it's gonna kill
them but they're not gonna have a choice
I said well wow that was pretty tough
flow and and he was right
earlier that week one of the people that
worked for me said you know what when I
was at I've got these people that want
to come in because when I was at AT&T
they had 15 layers of management and
they had this exercise which then became
really very strategic where they took
out 30% of management and and seven or
eight layers because people were too far
from the consumer and too far from you
know the business and they had built as
all businesses do of bureaucracy and so
I think we should look at this and I
said let me you know I tell me a little
bit more and she said well probably one
out of three middle to senior managers
is gonna have to go
and I said look we have all these
initiatives but we're really a people
based businesses we're not capital
intensive we're people intensive we have
so many countries the operating model is
not mature enough yet or matrix enough
for us to take out the people I
understand the concept I just don't I
don't think we can do that I mean I
think that would take it I don't think
we have the capacity I don't think we
can do that that was Monday Friday night
he says to me if you think about this
this is what's gonna happen Andrea so
you're gonna get fired if you don't turn
this around but then because you've got
it you know the history and the track
record Hydrox is gonna call you and
they're gonna put you into another
company and then you're gonna be the
turnaround CEO who gets to look at
everything fresh you won't know any of
the people you won't have any you know
allegiance to the strategies and you're
gonna go in and be able to just cut do
and change because you'll be objective
so you have to make a choice go home
it's Friday night if you can't come in
on Monday morning and reinvent yourself
and pretend you just got hired here and
you're gonna look at everything
your team your strategies your
organizational structure and if you
can't do the things that a turnaround
person would do if they came in here
Monday morning
I wouldn't put big bets on it if you can
you will be far better than anybody else
could because you know where every you
know rock is you know every single thing
about it and you've got the latent
goodwill and equity that you've built up
so you make the choice so that's what I
did I went home and I thought about it
and I came in Monday morning and we took
out eight layers we had we went forward
and and reshaped I had very hard look at
some people who were terrific friends
but and got us from you know three
billion to six billion but weren't gonna
get us to 11 and I made all the hard
calls with the right values and in the
rest has been the last few years but you
know I had to become a definer of my own
second chapter and started afresh so it
was it's been like a new job you
mentioned how you're able to motivate
and inspire your own employees you also
mentioned how the lessons that you've
learned from the other boards that you
serve on I'm wondering how you've been
able to adjust your leadership style to
mauvais inspire these more
technology-based companies and these
almost bigger than life personality is
these male leaders that those companies
I think that you know the experiences
that I've had at the company as well as
my own vantage point has been a
different and interesting addition to
the boards that I've been on the global
experience you know our our business in
China for example you know where we have
write direct touch consumer insights in
an understanding of in our case you know
a million won sellers who have millions
of consumers in all the small towns and
villages one of the things I just saw
you said
sample and it's been a lot of time
talking about that with Jeff Immelt or
Steve but we we decided it Avon not to
focus on the eastern seaboard cities the
large cities we decided to penetrate the
small towns and villages and have a
supply chain and infrastructure strategy
where the women were because we knew
that the government would like the fact
that we were offering opportunities for
people not to have to bust themselves to
work in two large cities that we could
create work for them right in the towns
and villages where they were and those
insights and the behavior and the
opportunity to understand consumers and
what they will do and what they will pay
in those countries those are some of the
insights I think I've been able to bring
very different personalities so they
mean two very different men and two very
different corporate cultures and ours is
completely different - and it is
interesting - to weigh and balance that
so again even though Avon is different
from either of those two those two
couldn't be more different either but
both with the enormous strengths out of
curiosity do you feel there still is a
glass ceiling and if so what do you
think the next generation of leaders can
do to change that that's a great
question
um you know I think the numbers by
themselves would say there's still
somewhat of a glass ceiling I mean 15
out of 500 you know I guess women in on
the fortune 500 would say there's
there's room to go but having said that
I am a real believer that the playing
field is changing and what do I mean by
that when I go back even five years
never mind when I became the CEO most
women in not the CEO job but in the
level underneath were in what I would
call the the staff jobs corporate
communications HR they were not in CFO
roles or the the leading operating unit
roles if you look today well the number
may be small in the the note that with
the level below of women ready to take
on the number one job or in the
importancy jobs the c-suite job it's so
dimensional that
I think the next five years is going to
be huge in terms of women in top
leadership roles in in in business so I
think we are in a in a very very
different moment also in terms of me I
mean you know I I keep saying you know
there's these lists which I believe that
when the lists go way of top whatever
women will really have made it but right
now while there are still lists you know
I'm hoping that I keep going down what
do I mean by that because I mean my
company's big but they're people in much
bigger jobs now in the top you know
fortune 50 companies and and so women
are not only breaking through but
they're breaking through with some
pretty big roles which I think hopefully
is true in politics is in business so I
think it's the jobs and the companies
they're leading as well as the number of
them who are ready to take on pretty
large roles very very different than
even five years ago so I think the glass
is very half-full more than half-full on
that front so it's a it's a different
time if women want it you know I mean I
think especially kind of where the
challenges and best practices and
leaving that as a great question how do
how do I stay innovative or out of one
stay innovative I mean I think you know
you guys are probably learning this more
than anyone that is that innovation is
so key I think this is more important
than ever I think that the worst thing
that can happen in this economy is for
people to cut back R&D spend I mean if
you kind of look at you know I I have
studied that the actual market share
gains and losses in normal or healthy
economies it's pretty hard when you're
large to kind of get half a point of
market share or a point takes a long
time and so in in normal times it's it's
hard but in this the worst economies
they say that that's when disruptive
shares gains or losses when industries
go out and companies can go from bottom
quartile to completely top if
they are on top of innovation so really
I'm a huge believer that this is
actually a seminal moment for companies
to invest and I think it's a combination
of things look one thing and I believe
this is that there there's a a deal of
instinct that that's important in
innovation I think you can't always find
it going back or in facts or analytics
or I mean if you really you have to have
I think some arc the art of it and the
instinct of it as well as the science
and facts but you know the consumer
herself or himself will will tell you a
good amount of the answer I mean you
know you can be searching out there but
if you really listen and and have the
constant tentacles into I find some of
the biggest answers in the customer
complaint area if you go into your call
center your customer complaint area
about your products and/or services you
know right in there from what they don't
like is the answer to what you can do so
it is just I go in there sit there
listen to the phone pick it up I've done
that for a couple hours you know every
once in a while and you can get a
tremendous amount there I wonder if we
could give us some information on how
you divide your time and make sure you
get these disciplines across your
children and and do the bang-up job at
home okay well my answer for this which
has evolved is the following I mean I
don't know I'm sure there are some
people who can get it all done in one
day I am NOT one of them but I really
believe two things one is there it's all
about prioritization there are days that
my children absolutely win in the
company does not there are also days
where the company has to win and they
don't and I think I have made the right
choice with the right priority so the
day's Avon lose I don't feel guilty if
I'm not at a meeting years ago I would
not go to an Avon meeting and I would
feel guilty about it the whole time I
don't do that anymore my probably best
example is this time it was this couple
of administration's ago so it was George
W Bush and they were
eight CEOs to the White House that was
the only woman invited on a specific
topic and it was also the first day that
my daughter was going away to a camp
that mothers were gonna take their kids
to the bus and you know it was one of
those things where it was like a split
second I mean I really thought George W
is never going to remember if I am at
that luncheon but my daughter is gonna
remember one way or another for the
probably the rest of her life so I
didn't go to the White House I got a
chance to go another time but and you
know that that decision was an easy one
have I missed a game yes have I met the
most important one no have I missed a
meeting at work yes the most important
one No
so for me it's just you know making it
making a decision like that